Mars I always wonder what it would be
like to live there and to build there
[Music]
what would it feel like to look out the
window and see an alien landscape
millions and millions of miles away from
everything we know although the exact
timeline is unclear we're definitely
planning for a new life on Mars and
we're putting a lot of money into it
NASA has plans to send their first human
missions sometime in 2030 SpaceX by 2029
and also establish a city of 1 million
by 2050 the Emirates plans to build a
human settlement by the year 21-17
although there are still a lot of
variables and unknowns in the last
couple of years we found potential water
they found organic molecules hinting to
signs of life and technology is
accelerating at an insane rate this
video is sponsored and brainstormed with
millidote more on them later in this
video
[Music]
the kardashev scale is a method of
assessing the technological capabilities
of a civilization based on the amount of
energy it can use and manipulate
a type 1 civilization has full control
over all of our energy sources we're
currently at type 0.72 but we are on
track to reaching type 1 and once we get
there according to kardashev we're gonna
have such a profound understanding of
Science and Technology we're going to be
able to manipulate matter and energy on
a molecular level we're going to have
control over the water patterns and
we're even going to be able to colonize
other planets so maybe it's just a
matter of time that humans start to
expand beyond our planet but what kind
of conditions do we need to build for
humans to really live there and not just
survive and is our species even ready
for this
[Music]
right now the focus for the next couple
decades is getting the first few
astronauts to live there for an extended
period of time but I think once that
mission is successful it's really a
matter of time until we get the first
pioneers for the selected test group
who's going to continue to do research
on Mars and the first settlers the first
Mars Community to permanently live there
and one day we will have a human Colony
on Mars they'll probably think and maybe
even look very different from us each of
these categories of people are going to
have a very different experience of Mars
depending on the technical apparatus of
that time and we're still quite a ways
away from being able to modify the
Martian atmosphere and be able to
experience Mars as we currently live on
earth right now we're in this very first
stage but this is a really critical
point because once we get past this Mark
where we're not just surviving but
thriving on Mars it's gonna open the
doors to A Whole New Frontier and
becoming a multi-planet species where we
could feel confident about creating new
habitats wherever we go
[Music]
there have been lots of different
proposals for habitation on Mars but it
seems like we are leaning towards a
construction method that's a combination
of prefabrication and 3D printing using
the local material on Mars so in 2019
NASA held a competition to design a 3D
printed habitat on Mars to house four
astronauts for the time span of a year
they were given a set of functional
requirements like a lab a kitchen a rec
room and one thousand square feet of
living space all designed for the
astronauts to conduct research while
living there if these habitats proved to
be successful these modules should be
easily replicable for further expansion
each of these proposals use a phase
strategy where they send autonomous
machines to first harvest the raw
Martian materials and then they create a
building material using the Martian soil
and other composites and then they 3D
print the initial framework for the
habitat before the astronauts actually
get there once this is built they outfit
the interior either through an
inflatable structure or any other
prefabricated components that come
together on the inside of the shawl
to make this video we looked at hundreds
of Articles and videos and we used
melanote to organize all of our Research
into something a little bit more
coherent melanote is extremely intuitive
with lots of templates that you can
choose from and for us having a visual
mind map like this always helps us make
connections that we didn't see before
you can very easily drag and drop images
and my favorite part is how it converts
links into thumbnails so you don't ever
need to download things all of this is
on the cloud so you can share it with
other people and it's completely free
with no time limits so you can sign up
using the link in the description I'm
actually really curious how you guys use
it so if you've tried it let me know in
the comments
foreign
[Music]
has to deal with a huge amount of
problems on Mars like radiation massive
temperature changes exposure to dust and
other contaminants changes in the
nervous system there's lower gravity
which can cause what they call a puffy
face chicken-like syndrome yes that's
what they that's what it's actually
called chicken leg syndrome and of
course you're really far away from
anything and everything including food
materials hospitals and Equipment even
if everything goes perfectly with the
engineering and the astronauts are
perfectly trained physically the mission
could still fail due to the human factor
isolation being far away from home
living in a confined high stress
environment it could lead to depression
and behavioral changes I mean we really
saw this during covet right
there are several places on Earth that
share similarities with the red planet
in fact some of them are used as
training grounds for astronauts but
these aren't necessarily the best
representation of how people are
actually going to live there because
Mars doesn't really have a living
surface with zero air pressure Mars is
essentially a vacuum use can't survive
without a suit you would black out in
like 20 seconds and if you try breathing
your lungs would rupture and you would
die within minutes in fact even the
harshest environment on Earth is still
gonna feel like heaven compared to Mars
but I think there's a few man-made
environments that do have some
similarities to living on Mars
foreign
house is a series of interconnected
components with a specific function
controlled by the inhabitants your
everyday life and Duties are entangled
with the structure as long as you live
there in some ways you become a part of
the lighthouse but you can still go out
and take fresh air and experience the
environment outside the lighthouse but
what happens if you take the concept of
a lighthouse to the extreme
just like on a Mars habitat people in a
submarine work together towards
completing a mission that could last
months each person has a very specific
job and they have to work together to
succeed and they do this while crammed
inside a pressurized steel hull with
very little personal space so the level
of pressure
get it is both physical and
psychological in each of these
self-contained conditions there's a real
profound connection between the
inhabitants and the places they live
because it can determine whether you
live or die
foreign
the most important part of a Martian
habitat is the shell that protects from
radiation and the Hostile climate so a
lot of these designs create a cave-like
condition there are some examples of
triadite settlements like the Matt Mata
underground houses in Tunisia Africa
which uses the Earth's mass to protect
themselves from the Heat and the
windstorms but even in these settlements
you still have access to the outdoors
this is also going to be the very first
time that humans are going to be living
in complete disconnect from the physical
environment so the way that this shawl
mediates the connection to the outside
environment is really important not just
for physical safety but also for a
psychological connection to the Martian
environment the project Kanye it's
designed with multiple glazed opening
and the buildings organized over three
stories so you can get a wide array of
different views into the outside
environment you also have these more
dome-shaped designs which are a little
bit more common which has one or two
fixed views the shell also affects the
functional organization and movement
within the habitat you'll see lots of
different forms in the design but you
can kind of divide them into two
distinct categories a vertical layout
and a horizontal layout within the
horizontal layout there's designs that
separated all of the functions into
their distinct pods and there's ones
that's Consolidated all of the functions
into one single pod if you're looking at
Courtyard typologies as a way to create
social interaction maybe an organization
like this makes a little bit more sense
these are probably the most efficient
structures in terms of applicability
because you can create more and you can
connect more pods but if it were me my
mental health would deteriorate real
fast in these types of Arrangements one
because they're highly highly monotonous
and you can see the same spaces same
walls from all different views two
there's very little separation between
functions
according to Edward T Hall we all have a
spatial Dimension that determines our
relationship to each other and to our
surroundings when these dimensions are
disrupted either by other people or by
poor design you can have really serious
psychological impacts and he calls this
idea proxemics
[Music]
in his book The Hidden Dimension he
talks about a crowding experiment in
Norway where they took a group of 48
rats and put them in an indoor
environment they were given everything
they needed except for personal space
there was a quick population boom
followed by such a severe psychological
and behavioral disruption that it
eventually led to their Extinction he
called these behavioral sinks it
distorted their behavior everything from
sex nest building birth territoriality
and a lot of the rats had tumors and
enlarged kidneys and large livers all of
which are signs of extreme stress the
crowding led to a pathological behavior
in the rats and although humans have for
the most part developed the level of
cognitive sophistication that makes us
think before we act the limbic system
which is a part of the brain that
controls our emotional processing and
motivation is still one of the oldest
parts of the brain and it has a direct
connection to the brain stem so our
reactions and behaviors are still very
influenced by our instincts and just
like animals we still have an
instinctive spatial Dimension that
influences how we interact in different
environments even if we have physical
separations or the most advanced virtual
reality technology we still need to
think about these invisible Dimensions
as extensions of our bodies and not just
that these invisible dimensions are also
based on things like cultural background
and the nature of the relationship
between the people there's an example in
the book of Japanese walls versus German
walls in Japanese culture for really
long time they've used Paper Walls and
paper doors so Japanese people all can
selectively filter out auditory
information and they speak more softly
while German people they need really
thick soundproof walls otherwise they'd
feel intruded on in loud atmospheres if
we want to create an enclosed
environment where we try to avoid
conflict as much as possible we really
need to consider these invisible
dimensions and not just the performance
surprise
these two proposals divide the functions
vertically and these ones divide the
functions into individual pods the
horizontal layout definitely provides
more separation in X house the sleeping
area is the same pod as the lab which
connects to the lab and the gym in the
other pod and there's another pod for
the kitchen and the two vertical
proposals have all the functions
separated into different but
interconnected floors comparing the two
layouts my preference would definitely
be the vertical one and my reason is
because even in the most technical
environments in a fact especially in the
most technical and rigorous environments
I think you need a sense of variability
and surprise something that's not
planned these people are going to be
living in the same environment doing the
same thing with the same people eating
the same freaking food every single day
for a year everything is scheduled
everything
planned and there's absolutely no
surprise this type of arrangement means
that if I want to go to the kitchen I go
to the kitchen if I want to go to the
lab I'll go this way and I'll go to the
lab it's really efficient and it's
really purposeful but I think in such a
high stress environment you need a
little bit of space to roam without
purpose even if it's like one percent of
the time with this vertical layout if
you want to get to the lap you have to
get past the garden and the kitchen and
in those moments you might run into
another crew or you might find some
other activity that's going on and the
result is you don't just get a variety
and attractions but also a variety in
experiences as well you get a sense of
scale and hierarchy and a sense of
surprise instead of having everything
visible in your face environments like
this creates a sense of curiosity and it
creates atmosphere the Kanye's project
also has a vertical organization but in
this case it incorporates a garden at
the ground level that each of the floors
can look down onto one of the
competition's program requirements was a
garden and a lot of these other projects
provided a highly efficient Hydroponics
Garden but again I really like how this
design creates an informal unplanned
space while also dual functioning as a
garden
there's constant messaging around these
Explorations we need to design for
people to thrive not just survive and of
course the safety and efficiency of
these habitats are very very important
they're going to form the basis for our
attitude towards inhabiting foreign
Landscapes so I think it's some of these
intangible qualities even though they're
hard to quantify that can really make
the difference between a research
Mission and a new and exciting vision
for the future
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]